j'ai pu construire des modèles
qui peuvent prédire toutes sortes d'attributs cachés
sur vous sans savoir que
vous partagez ce genre d'informations.
En tant que scientifiques, on utilise ça pour aider
les gens à mieux interagir en ligne,
mais il y a aussi des utilisations bien moins altruistes,
et le problème est que les utilisateurs ne comprennent pas
vraiment ces techniques ni comment elles fonctionnent,
et même s'ils les comprenaient, ils ne peuvent pas les contrôler.
Donc, j'aimerais vous parler aujourd'hui
de certaines de ces choses que l'on peut faire,
et donner une petite idée sur comment
redonner un peu de ce contrôle aux utilisateurs.
Voici Target, l'entreprise.
Je n'ai pas mis ce logo
sur le ventre de cette femme enceinte.
Vous avez peut-être entendu parler de cette histoire:
Target a envoyé
un prospectus à cette jeune fille de 15 ans
avec de la publicité et des ristournes
pour des biberons, des langes et des berceaux
deux semaines avant qu'elle ne dise à ces parents
qu'elle était enceinte.
Oui, le père n'était pas content.
Il a dit : « Comment Target a-t-il compris
que cette ado était enceinte
avant même qu'elle le dise à ces parents ? »
En fait, Target garde un historique d'achat
pour des centaines de milliers de clients
et ils calculent ce qu'ils appellent un score de grossesse,
qui ne dit pas simplement si une femme est enceinte ou pas,
mais aussi sa date d'accouchement.
Et ils calculent cela
pas en regardant ce qui est flagrant,
comme le fait qu'elle achète un berceau ou des vêtements pour bébés,
mais comme le fait qu'elle achète plus de vitamines
que d'habitude,
ou elle a acheté un sac
assez grand pour y mettre des langes.
Seuls, ces achats ne semblent pas
révéler grand chose,
mais c'est une suite de comportements qui,
quand vous le prenez dans un contexte de milliers d'autres personnes,
commence à donner une certaine idée.
C'est ce genre de choses-là que l'on fait
quand on prédit des choses sur vous sur les médias sociaux.
On va chercher des suites de comportements qui,
quand vous les détectez parmi des millions de gens,
nous permet de trouver des tas de choses.
Dans mon laboratoire, avec mes collègues,
nous avons développé des mécanismes qui nous permettent
de prédire certaines choses très précisément,
comme votre penchant politique,
votre score de personnalité, votre sexe, orientation sexuelle,
religion, âge, intelligence,
comme aussi
si vous faites confiance aux gens que vous connaissez
et si ces liens sont forts ou pas.
On peut savoir tout ça très facilement.
Et de nouveau, ça ne vient pas forcément
d'informations flagrantes.
Mon exemple préféré vient de cette étude
publiée il y a un an
dans les « Proceedings of the National Academies ».
Vous pouvez la trouver sur Google.
Quatre pages, très faciles à lire.
Ils n'ont regardé que les mentions « J'aime » de Facebook,
ce que vous pouvez aimer sur Facebook,
et utilisé ça pour prédire toutes ces caractéristiques,
et d'autres encore.
Et dans leur article, ils ont listé ces 5 mentions « J'aime »
les plus indicatives d'une grande intelligence.
Et parmi celles-là, il y avait un mention « J'aime »
pour les frites bouclées. (Rires)
C'est délicieux les frites bouclées,
mais les aimer ne veut pas nécessairement dire
que vous êtes plus intelligent que la moyenne.
Donc, comment cela se fait-il qu'un des indicateurs les plus importants
de votre intelligence
est le fait d'aimer cette page
alors que le contenu est sans rapport
avec l'attribut qu'il prédit ?
Nous avons dû étudier
toute une série de théories
pour comprendre comment on peut y arriver.
L'une d'elle est une théorie sociale appelée homophilie,
qui dit que les gens sont en général amis avec des gens comme eux.
Si vous êtes intelligents, vous allez être amis avec des gens intelligents,
et si vous êtes jeunes, vous allez être amis avec des jeunes,
C'est un fait averé
depuis des centaines d'années.
On sait aussi
comment les informations se répandent sur les réseaux.
En fait, les vidéos virales
ou les mentions « J'aime » sur Facebook ou d'autres informations
se répandent de la même façon
que les maladies.
C'est quelque chose qu'on étudie depuis longtemps.
On en a fait de bon modèles.
On peut donc mettre toutes ces choses ensemble
et voir pourquoi ce genre de choses arrive.
Donc, si je devais faire une hypothèse :
c'est quelqu'un d'intelligent qui a commencé cette page,
ou qu'une des premières personnes qui l'a aimée
avait un haut score d'intelligence.
Et il l'a aimé, et ses amis l'ont vu,
et par homophilie, on sait qu'il a des amis intelligents,
et ça s'est répandu chez eux, et ils l'ont aimé,
et ils avaient des amis intelligents,
et ça s'est répandu chez eux,
et comme ça à travers le réseau,
chez plein de gens intelligents,
et donc à la fin, l'action
d'aimer la page des frites bouclées
est indicative d'une grande intelligence,
pas à cause du contenu,
mais à cause de l'action même d'aimer
qui reflète les attributs communs
à tous ces autres qui l'ont aimé aussi.
Ça à l'air très compliqué, non ?
Ce n'est pas facile à expliquer
à un utilisateur moyen, et même en le faisant,
que peut-il y faire ?
Comment pouvez-vous savoir que vous avez aimé quelque chose
qui indique un trait qui pour vous
n'a rien à voir avec le contenu de ce que vous avez aimé ?
Et les utilisateurs n'ont aucun pouvoir
à contrôler comment ces données sont utilisées.
Et pour moi, c'est un vrai problème pour le futur.
Il y a, je pense, plusieurs chemins
que nous pouvons regarder
si nous voulons donner un peu de contrôle aux utilisateurs
sur l'utilisation de ces données,
parce qu'elles ne vont pas toujours être utilisées
à leur avantage.
Un exemple que je donne souvent est que
si un jour ça m'ennuie d'être professeur,
je lancerai une entreprise
qui prédit tous ces attributs
et des choses comme le fait de bien travailler en équipe
et si vous prenez des drogues et êtes alcoolique.
Nous savons comment prédire tout ça.
Et je vais vendre ces rapports
à de grandes entreprises et des compagnies R.H.
qui voudraient vous engager.
On peut faire ça maintenant.
Je pourrais commencer ça demain,
et vous n'auriez absolument aucun contrôle
sur le fait que j'utiliserais vos données comme ça.
Pour moi, ça c'est un problème.
Donc, un des chemins que l'on pourrait prendre
est celui de la politique et de la loi.
Et ça serait sans doute le chemin le plus efficace,
mais le problème est qu'il faudrait le faire vraiment.
Connaissant les procédures politiques
ça m'étonnerait vraiment
qu'on arrive à ce que des représentants
s'asseyent, prennent connaissance de ceci,
et promulguent des changements de grande envergure
sur les lois sur la propriété intellectuelle aux USA
pour que les utilisateurs contrôlent leurs données.
On pourrait prendre le chemin politique,
où les compagnies de médias sociaux diraient :
« Vous savez quoi ? Vos données sont à vous.
C'est vous qui contrôlez comment elles sont utilisées. »
Le problème est que les modèles de revenus
de la plupart de ces entreprises
dépendent du partage et de l'exploitation des données des utilisateurs.
On dit de Facebook, que les utilisateurs
ne sont pas les clients, ils sont le produit.
Comment demander à une entreprise
de redonner le contrôle de son capital
aux usagers ?
C'est possible, mais je ne pense pas
que ça se réalise rapidement.
L'autre chemin
que l'on pourrait prendre et qui serait aussi efficace
est plus scientifique.
C'est la science qui nous a permis de développer
ces mécanismes calculant
ces données personnelles.
Et ce sont des recherches similaires
qu'il va falloir faire
si nous voulons développer des mécanismes
qui peuvent dire aux usagers :
« Tu as fais ça, voici le risque encouru. »
En aimant cette page Facebook,
ou en partageant cette information personnelle,
tu viens de m'aider
à pouvoir prédire le fait que tu te drogues ou pas
ou que tu t'entendes bien avec tes collègues de travail.
Et ça peux affecter le fait que
les gens veulent partager quelque chose,
le garder privé, ou ne pas le mettre en ligne du tout.
On peut aussi décider de
laisser les gens encoder les données qu'ils mettent en ligne,
pour qu'elles soient invisibles et inutiles
pour des sites comme Facebook
ou des tiers qui y ont accès,
mais que seuls des utilisateurs choisis
peuvent y accéder.
Ce sont des recherches très intéressantes
d'un point de vue intellectuel,
et donc les scientifiques vont les faire.
Ça nous donne aussi un avantage sur le côté légal.
Un des problèmes dont parlent les gens
quand je lance ce sujet est, ils disent,
que si les gens gardent toutes ces données privées,
toutes ces méthodes qu'on a développées
pour prédire leurs traits ne vont plus fonctionner.
Et je réponds : « Absolument, et pour moi, ça serait un succès,
parce qu'en tant que scientifique,
mon objectif n'est pas de déduire des informations sur les utilisateurs,
mais d'améliorer la façon dont les gens interagissent en ligne.
Et parfois ça implique de déduire des choses sur eux,
mais s'ils ne veulent pas que j'utilise ces données,
ils devraient avoir le droit de le faire.
Je veux que les utilisateurs soient informés et consentants
sur les outils que nous développons.
Donc, encourager cette science
et ses chercheurs
qui veulent rendre un peu de ce contrôle aux utilisateurs
et le prendre à ces compagnies de médias sociaux
veux dire qu'aller de l'avant, alors que ces outils se développent
et s'améliorent,
veux dire que l'on va avoir des utilisateurs
éduqués et responsabilisés,
et je crois qu'on est tous d'accord
que c'est de cette façon-là que l'on doit avancer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)